so it's like it's like these people are
waiting for motives to happen just so
they have some new content yeah it's
[ __ ] weird it was so weird yeah yeah
yeah it's like everyone just saw Tiger
King and it's just like yeah just just
do even before it was making a Mojo
where it all started oh making them
making a murderer just turned True Crime
into like the biggest goddamn thing and
people could not stop talking about it
no one cares now what happened to him no
no no one used to [ __ ] but on YouTube
it's like there's like a billion
channels that are like today for your
daily dose of murder it's like what this
is so strange the power murderer of the
week is I I I've mentioned a few times
on the podcast I do feel weird when I
listen to this stuff yeah
it's hard to You'll you listen to it
you're like no it's interesting and then
you do sit back a little bit you're like
this is kind of strange that we're like
kind of doing this for entertainment and
we're kind of there's a way to do it
maybe is there a way to do it I feel
like
I think there's a way to do it
Tastefully but sometimes you can tell
it's like they've just scrolled through
the book of murders and it's been like
no this one will do for this video today
you know what I mean it does feel like
they're kind of just whatever will work
yeah it's not really an interesting
story I always know when a new Mr anime
video comes out because I inevitably get
tagged in it on Twitter you're like oh
they use your clip because okay so what
happened is one of the founding fathers
of anime YouTube
so he ended up
um murdering his entire family
like and uh and so this was like this
was back when anime YouTube was like
just a blip you know 2013 2013 or
something it was like way before that
it's like literally the start of YouTube
yeah
like that I don't know whatever like I
made a video about it at the time
because I was like one of them the
problem no I made a video being like
guys I'm bothered I'm sad you know
because this this thing happened and
then and then this thing that happens in
like one small community ages ago now is
like being used as like a topic for True
Crime uh and like like the YouTuber I've
noticed that YouTuber that does X thing
a bad thing is like such songs everyone
clicks on it I mean YouTube was arrested
you know this is literally almost viewed
highlight video
yeah no I'm do you remember when content
around YouTubers started to like become
a thing because I remember when it
started I was like this is never why
would people want to watch content about
other YouTube
how do you feel about all the people
doing like the history of feelings or
whatever
I Rose to the top
generic videos about it yeah I find it
hard to watch those I don't know why
even though they're usually positive I'm
just like uh I don't like hearing about
myself it feels weird yeah yeah I don't
like an essay format yeah but is that
what you meant oh yeah like that kind of
stuff or they document you or document
your controversies or document anything
it's like um is it just like tiresome I
don't know is it just no another one no
it's more like I don't like watching I
guess you I just feel weird when it's
about yourself you're like I don't yeah
yeah it's weird to watch yeah I mean you
can't get to the number one spot at any
given time and not have people make
videos about you right so yeah you can't
really complain about it yeah yeah I'm
sure I follow like what you mean though
like what type of videos well there's a
lot of channels that like oh when they
get into controversy like the downfall
of oh yeah yeah yeah I don't think I had
no you haven't you haven't had any of
those or maybe they
[Applause]
they just document your history on
YouTube and they try and like tell
everyone about your history and you're
like must be weird watching it from yeah
someone who knows yourself yeah it would
feel weird it's weird because like like
I said it's become like a massive Trend
within the past few years these videos
get millions and millions of views and
yeah yeah I I people like YouTubers that
[ __ ] up they like watching the best
thing yeah love watching I just think
they're doing it on everyone else
I think they're also just because
they're like such unique case studies
because it's like the way that a
YouTuber [ __ ] up is unlike how any
other celebrity [ __ ] up I mean and and
a lot of the times it's so well
documented I'm like right it's like
celebrity so it's just like oh well then
let's [ __ ] put it in a timeline yeah
make it sound you know have someone to
do that yeah well you choose to [ __ ] up
and they'll be like no absolutely not no
one can associate with them and then R
Kelly will literally like do the worst
thing on earth they'll be like I mean
come on though this song's pretty good
though I mean it's kind of banging it's
just like yeah what is this this is kind
of like yeah it is yeah I think it's
just because of the The Best Thing
YouTube is that [ __ ] up just need to
release it's because we don't have
anything we don't like fantasize like
all like build up YouTubers in the same
way that we do celebrities right like
celebrities are meant to be like
otherworldly they're supposed to be at
our level you know like Kanye is like
insane and does all this weird stuff and
we don't expect them to act like like a
normal person
yeah it's kind of like when you get that
big and like a music or any kind of
thing it's kind of hold them to a
different standard weirdly I don't know
yeah it seems to kind of mellow down
though for both yeah I think so yeah
well the more that social media kind of
yeah crosses
and you realize celebrities say things
they didn't say things before because
they had to go on a talk show and you're
like oh oh they're a flat earther oh I
would never have found that out before
she didn't do that
you're not a glober are you disgusting
yeah the best celebrities are the ones
that usually don't say that much yeah
yeah yeah I mean you can use private
ones yeah yeah oh that's when they
idolize you the most because you're
mysterious right it's like oh I don't I
don't know what Tom Hanks does he's so
nice
don't ruin Tom Hanks for me
X's son have you seen the videos of Tom
hanks's son no he saw he was on a
channel 5 news that channel where they
it was very oh was he I didn't know yeah
a bit of an interesting online presence
oh really
what's he saying
my children will not embarrassing
embarrass me all right
if you imagine Tom Hanks a behavior
imagine the complete 180 why does that
happen with so many people I I feel like
with a lot of like my hypothetical child
no way yeah it's not happening well I
feel like with a lot of like celebrity
kids they're never gonna like the kids
are never gonna have the same experience
their parents did because their parents
are this Mega like famous parents would
you let your kids ever go anywhere on
camera no oh near a camera yeah if your
kid is hypothetic when and if you have
our kids hypothetical children
and if one day they were like Daddy I
want to be a YouTuber [ __ ] no
absolutely not absolutely not stupid
child
what if you're become a YouTuber and he
was a bad one done you're done
stop filming right now yeah this is
trash yeah let me see your metrics right
now
you call these numbers
like give me that Mouse I'll [ __ ]
make your thumbnail for you
will not do child get rid of it change
it he's like literally eight years old
you disgrace the family name I have
someone on Fiverr like everyone else
took you two years to get the gold play
button just discipline
the worst part is they'll probably do
like whatever there's 10 times worse
than Tick Tock in the future
I think Casey neistat doesn't show his
kids face on camera right would you do
that would you no don't give a [ __ ]
you're like that's like a moral thing
isn't it I don't know I don't know what
you do whatever you when you get there
you'll figure it out I mean tell us
right now we need to scoop right now
Felix we gotta get this children
a lot of babies are ugly right
so does this question depend on if your
kid is beautiful it comes out with like
the Squidward face let me get there so
basically if my baby is [ __ ] gorgeous
asked me if I was an ugly baby I was
like no it was beautiful
how the [ __ ] would you know that but
I've only seen like one cute photo of me
so I'm sure like there's like ugly
babies no I was an ugly baby probably
but that's the thing like you film a
little baby and you put it out there
like yeah
Kobe's the number one YouTuber and being
a pretty baby that's not fair that's
just like you gotta balance it out
someone else everyone has a humble
beginnings like some stuff that babies
do are like kind of embarrassing and I
would not want that footage of that out
there even though about my baby right
yeah yeah I think that's where I could
be worse
I'm speaking
yeah because I guess that's like the the
weird like moral compass right because
it's like now that now that there's so
many uh like you know YouTubers who are
becoming parents right it's like okay so
I follow the parents who become
YouTubers parents who become YouTube
because they have kids do something yeah
it's like come on make money for me yeah
the [ __ ] clip where that Mum forces
the kids like oh I got a cry more for
the thumbnail I'm like oh yeah
thumbnail face right now yeah some of
them are so sad like I didn't want to
bring it up yeah there's so many family
vloggers have just gone to [ __ ]
completely yeah I'll remember the whole
[ __ ] daddy 05 situation I I did so
much stupid [ __ ] when I was like eight
to twelve even to 16 honestly yeah like
I just can't imagine if my mum filmed it
and put it online like I once was I was
I was playing the Pokemon trading card
game with my Game Boy SP another one of
the yeah yeah I know I was just paying
and I dropped it in the toilet right
while I was peeing because I was
literally pissing while playing it so
addictive what's your posture if you
drop it in there I'm standing standing
pissing playing it dropped it inside
and he was even embarrassing enough
because my parents wouldn't stop telling
people who we met that I I was peeing
and I dropped my Game Boy and as a kid
this was like soul-crushing oh yeah of
course and I was like what if my parents
did this it would be like the thumbnail
be oh drop Game Boy
tell them how you were pissing yourself
and you dropped it in the toilet
reenacting yeah I'd be like out of the
toilet we'll get the thumbnail shot
right I genuinely think I would get like
trauma yeah I'd get like PTSD or
something exactly it wouldn't be like a
normal functioning human being yeah all
right like okay say say we all have kids
right at what age would you be like if
your kid comes to you and goes dad I
want to be an influencer or a tick
tocker or a YouTuber whatever at what
age is it just like okay you're old
enough go go for your dreams I'd say
like
sixteen sixteen yeah like to the point
where it's like because it's like
anything younger than that it's like
they don't know
so you need to you need to have like I
feel like to be a successful uh YouTuber
anything like that you just need to like
grow up with the internet and like and
be involved in like the yeah be on the
viewing side for a while so that you can
like you know understand it from the
viewing position yeah I was always
addicted to being online yeah yeah yeah
I couldn't 100 couldn't get me off yeah
but like you see these YouTubers were
like you know 13 12 years old and I'm
just like how are you like functioning
right now because it's all for them yeah
because it's like I didn't know what the
[ __ ] I was doing when I was 12 13 years
old and it's like and now you're you
have a million eyes on you yeah that's
[ __ ] weird it's like that would be
terrifying yeah and I also don't want to
be you know I don't want the situation
of like my [ __ ] 12 year old coming to
me being like Dad so people are saying
mean things on the internet and like
what the only thing I can say is you're
weak
[Applause]
upload that's that's all that just
delete the comment bro you'll be all
right you might actually make a monster
as well who just like can't be like
criticized and he just doesn't accept
anything because he's been taught from
like age 12 to ignore everything
everyone says online yeah just what do
you mean I have to do whatever I want
I'd be like telling my kid off and it'd
be like I've heard worse on my comments
dad you fell off your channel I'm not
listening to you yeah
what about what about the age you'd
first allow them to like upload the
first video they're not uploading any
videos
like go ahead but I'm gonna make sure
they don't yeah when you were kids like
put anything else yeah like Xbox
gameplay no audio or anything I used to
put up [ __ ] on like deviantART back in
the day hell yeah is it still up yeah
because I forgot my password so now I
can't believe that the anime man
thankfully someone's gonna find this now
they used to let you have like the
theater and the clipping thing oh yeah
yeah there's my sick Tomahawk kill oh
[ __ ] yeah Black Ops some of those are
pretty sick some of them are pretty sick
all right they bounce off the walls and
[ __ ] and like slow-mo into the man who
goes
that was real [ __ ] my first was a Death
Note AMV really what yeah I thought it
was the winner well I mean I lost it's
okay it's gone in the if there's
somewhere how old were you when you made
that I probably must have been 16. wait
wait so you've been watching anime since
you're like 16. I think so yeah I
thought you got into it when you were
like 20 something
no
um I think I think uh yeah I got into it
maybe yeah how did you find that yeah
how did you find out about anime yeah uh
my friend was really into it and he got
me into it
yeah what song what song did you choose
for your death note AMV let me guess was
it Lincoln yeah we gotta take a guess
yeah
I was I was trying to find it like I
searched YouTube and like upload date
like 10 years
what compelled you to make a definite I
thought it was [ __ ] cool it was dope
I showed it to my mom and everything I'm
like Mom check them out check out
Windows Movie Maker yeah as a parent you
must be pretty impression if your kid
makes anything you're like wow you did
something yeah you don't do anything you
normally just sit around and annoy me
like this yeah the first video my mom
saw she was just like wow you speak
English what the [ __ ]
she didn't know I guess no wait that
must be so trippy with your kid just
knew a language you're like what the
[ __ ] because I learned like from talking
to people online just gaming and stuff
yeah it was crazy because your accent is
like I mean not really that Swedish no
it's kind of weird yeah neutralized
accent that's [ __ ] awful so you learn
via gamer lingo yeah I guess so oh my
God yeah because I always notice when
you play games in EU right you always
used to play online yeah and you would
just be like oh yeah I'm 12 from Norway
I've post perfect English I don't know
I've been playing games since I was like
two that's why and it's just like what
the [ __ ] is going on in these countries
but then every every single kid from the
Netherlands is just fluent by itself too